it's the second to final stage of the
Tour de swiss and the tinkov saxo chase
car rides behind the race on board for
Britt co-directs the team of eight
riders as morale is down heel flat or a
field they're pinning their stage hopes
on one rider roman kreuziger we have one
of the best prime x ESO today it would
be real important I really believe they
can win today so is a detail on the
downhill cyclists go faster than 100
kilometres an hour but it co has raced
for years he's broken both arms both
collar bones and ribs I'm sorry weather
sometimes fight for the job to
profession and to be back as really hard
we have one guide here there's a some
phenomenal read your suffering you can't
sleep I justify today coming to the
Batman the other cop midway through the
race a group of eight riders breaks away
from the peloton Fabrizio makes the
decision not to chase instead they'll
protect their climber Roman and bide
their time stay around in corvo him in
any situation the other seven riders
will spend the race protecting Roman
from the wind they sacrifice their
chances of winning for the leader after
nearly 200 kilometers of riding through
the Swiss valleys for pretty old makes
the call to attack the mountain is in
sight aliamanu alley after this drive is
bunch the winner of this stage will be
decided on the hill climb up to the ski
resort of verbier a dash to the finish
early man I live all male Ramos the
summer stock explains down the radio to
his lead
I die die die die codina 1500 aroma come
on that's good but it's not enough yeah
it was second yeah we finished second
that's good but you know we were close
to win today Roman finishes three
seconds behind the winner close but
disappointing Angus Bennett Bloomberg